as you know Barack Hussein Obama was the
worst president America has ever had and
not just because he stood by while zayn
quit 1d but because of the thousands of
laws and rules he passed to ruin our
country that's why i was thrilled to see
that president Trump's number one agenda
item was screw that guy and it's also
why i began running a series of segments
to celebrate every time president trump
overturns an obama arrow rule or
regulation called trumping obama now to
recap this series so far trump has
suspended daca restricted travel to cuba
withdrawn from the trans-pacific
partnership and pulled out of the paris
climate Accord and that's just the tip
of the totally not melting iceberg roll
the wholeness chuck oh yeah so look at
him read and weep there bearing huh
it's impressive it's long it's taking
too long Chuck we just beat it up speed
it up yes 109 Obama rules rolled back
and today it's time for number 110 check
it out the Federal Communications
Commission is moving forward with its
plans to dismantle rules regarding net
neutrality that could allow internet
providers more control over what
consumers see and access online and how
fast websites run the FCC is expected to
pull the plug on the Obama era
regulations in three weeks uh Obama era
regulations if I hated that sentence
anymore I know at alimony
net neutrality is the set of FCC rules
that force companies to treat the
internet like a public utility and allow
everyone equal access it's nuanced
complicated issue but really all you
need to know is that Obama expanded it
so Trump has no choice but to obliterate
it so I got my trumping Obama punch card
right here let me find number 110 right
there oh nice
only 40 more and I get to destroy a
Prius in front of student Sarandon can't
wait now let me break down why it is
absolutely essential that Trump rid us
from the scourge of net neutrality
Exhibit A for years free thinkers like
Alex and Rush have known about the
dangers of net neutrality specifically
giving the government control over
anything is just bad you want Obama ISM
to be in charge of what you can and
can't do and where you can and can't do
it and how much you can or can't pay for
it on the internet then by all means
support net neutrality this is just a
high-tech version of what the Soviets
and the Nazis and the Chinese Communists
and Fidel Castro and every other nutball
did it is Obamacare for the internet
that's what Ted Cruz has come out and
said yeah Obamacare for the Internet do
you really want to be on your parents
internet until you're 26
yeah just like Obamacare net neutrality
is socialist the internet can't be for
everyone it's not a gun but the legacy
media is using fancy trickery and their
so-called facts to say that repealing
net neutrality will actually be terrible
for truth-tellers like me The Daily
Beast wrote sites like Infowars & 4chan
would likely be the first to have their
website slowed down by telecoms in the
new plan okay
nice try libs this is a loss for us we
never lose we all twin you're not gonna
get us by appealing to reason or logic
if I cared about logic that I wouldn't
hold the world record for eating the
most pounds of gravel in an hour only
head to e5 the prize money paid for my
esophagus surgery bonus just because
something is bad for you doesn't mean
you shouldn't do it opposing net
neutrality is a small price to pay for
serving a big old loss to Obama Pelosi
Hillary and the loonie left plus I don't
care if net neutrality makes it harder
for other people to hear my message I
see that as a challenge me and my
Breitbart boys and info gals got popular
because we were on the fringe the fringe
year we become the stronger we grow in
fact I'm not even waiting for the net
neutrality rules to go away I'm pushing
my truth to obscurity right now check it
out
this right here this is the only way
I'll be tweeting from now on handwritten
messages stuffed in a bottle that I
hurled into the Hudson that's how
they're getting out
I like to say CNN have that kind of
exclusive content and I'm pretty sure
I'm gonna pull the plug on the radio
show and replace it with Tim doing for
hour-long smoke signal rants we will
literally have the hottest takes in the
biz
[Music]